donde vi a 3 niños pequeños jugando con juguetes de plástico idénticos.
Se tenía que deslizar el botón rojo, y un perrito lindo saldría.
Una niña intentó tirar del botón púrpura, luego lo empujó,
y luego se echó hacia atrás y miró a la caja, con su labio inferior temblando.
El niño pequeño a su lado vio que esto sucedía,
se volvió hacia su caja y se echó a llorar, sin siquiera tocarla.
Mientras tanto, otra niña intentó todo lo que podía pensar
hasta que deslizó el botón rojo,
el perrito lindo saltó, y ella gritaba de alegría.
Así que 3 niños pequeños con juguetes de plástico idénticos,
pero con muy diferentes reacciones al fracaso.
Los primeros dos eran perfectamente capaces de deslizar el botón rojo.
Lo único que les impedía tener éxito
era que su mente los engañó haciéndoles creer que no podían.
Ahora, los adultos se dejan engañar de esta manera también, todo el tiempo.
Todos tenemos un conjunto predeterminado de sentimientos
y creencias que se desencadenan
cada vez que nos encontramos con frustraciones y reveses.
¿Son conscientes de cómo su mente reacciona al fracaso?
Tienen que hacerlo.
Porque si su mente trata de convencerlos de que son incapaces de algo
y Uds. se lo creen,
entonces como esos dos pequeñitos, comenzarán a sentirse indefensos
y dejarán de intentar demasiado pronto, o ni siquiera tratará en absoluto.
Entonces estarán aún más convencidos de que no pueden triunfar
Ven, es por eso que tantas personas actúan por debajo de su potencial real.
Porque en algún punto del camino, a veces por una sola falla,
se convencen de que no podían triunfar y creyeron en eso.
Una vez nos convencemos de algo, es muy difícil cambiar nuestra mente.
Aprendí esa lección de la forma difícil de adolescente con mi hermano.
Íbamos en coche con unos amigos por un camino oscuro por la noche,
cuando la policía nos detuvo.
Había habido un robo en la zona y estaban buscando a los sospechosos.
El oficial se acercó al coche, y alumbró con su linterna al conductor,
luego a mi hermano en el asiento delantero, y luego a mí.
Y sus ojos se abrieron y dijo:
"¿Dónde he visto su cara antes?"
(Risas)
Y yo dije: "En el asiento delantero".
Pero eso no tenía sentido para él en absoluto.
Así que ahora pensó que yo estaba en las drogas.
(Risas)
Así que me sacó del coche, buscó antecedentes,
me llevó al coche de la policía,
y solo cuando verificó que no tenía antecedentes penales,
pude demostrarle que tenía un gemelo en el asiento delantero.
Pero incluso mientras íbamos hacia el coche, se podía ver en su rostro
que estaba convencido de que yo estaba metido en algo.
Nuestra mente es difícil cambiar una vez nos convencemos de algo.
Puede ser muy natural sentirse derrotado y desmoralizado después de fracasar.
Pero no se pueden dejar convencer de que no pueden triunfar.
Tiene que luchar contra los sentimientos de impotencia.
Tiene que tomar el control de la situación
y de romper este tipo de ciclo negativo antes de que comience.
Nuestras mentes y nuestros sentimientos,
no son los amigos de confianza que pensábamos que eran.
Son más como un amigo temperamental,
que puede apoyarte un minuto, y ser realmente desagradable al siguiente.
Una vez trabajé con una mujer
que después de 20 años de matrimonio y un divorcio muy feo
estaba finalmente lista para su primera cita.
Había conocido a un hombre en línea, y él parecía agradable y parecía exitoso,
y más importante, parecía realmente interesado en ella.
Así que ella estaba muy emocionada, compró un vestido nuevo,
y se pusieron cita en un exclusivo bar de Nueva York para tomar una copa.
Diez minutos antes de la cita, el hombre se levanta y dice,
"No estoy interesado" y se va.
El rechazo es extremadamente doloroso.
Estaba tan herida que no podía moverse.
Lo único que pudo hacer fue llamar a un amigo.
Esto es lo que dijo el amigo: "Bueno, ¿qué esperas?
Tienes caderas grandes, no tienes nada interesante que decir,
¿por qué un hombre guapo, exitoso como este
querría alguna vez salir con una perdedora como tú?"
¿Sorprendente, verdad? Que un amigo pudiera ser tan cruel.
Pero sería mucho menos impactante
si le dijera que no fue el amigo quien dijo eso.
Es lo que se dijo la mujer a sí misma.
Y eso es algo que todos hacemos, especialmente después de un rechazo.
Empezamos a pensar en todas nuestras fallas y todos nuestros defectos,
lo que nos gustaría ser, lo que no,
nos ponemos etiquetas.
Tal vez no tan duramente, pero todos lo hacemos.
Y es interesante que lo hagamos, porque nuestra autoestima ya está herida.
¿Por qué íbamos a querer ir y dañarla aún más?
No empeoraríamos un daño físico a propósito.
No te cortas el brazo y decides: "¡Ah, ya sé!
Voy a tomar un cuchillo y ver cuánto más profundo que puedo hacerlo".
Pero lo hacemos con las lesiones psicológicas todo el tiempo.
¿Por qué? Debido a la falta de higiene emocional.
Debido a que no priorizamos nuestra salud psicológica.
Sabemos por docenas de estudios que cuando la autoestima es baja,
uno es más vulnerable al estrés y la ansiedad,
que los fracasos y rechazos duelen más y se tarda más en recuperarse de ellos.
Así que cuando se es rechazado, lo primero que se debe hacer
es para revivir la autoestima, no unirse al club de la pelea y darse una paliza.
Cuando estás en dolor emocional,
trátate con la misma compasión que esperarías de un verdadero buen amigo.
Tenemos que atrapar nuestros hábitos psicológicos insalubres y cambiarlos.
Uno de los más insanos y más comunes se llama rumiar.
Rumiar significa masticar más.
Es cuando tu jefe te grita, o tu profesor te hace sentir estúpido en clase,
o si tiene gran pelea con un amigo
y uno no puede dejar de reproducir la escena en la cabeza durante días,
a veces durante semanas.
Rumiar sobre eventos molestos puede convertirse fácilmente en un hábito,
y es muy costoso.
Porque pasar tanto tiempo enfocados en pensamientos perturbadores y negativos,
en realidad se ponen en riesgo significativo
de desarrollar depresión clínica, alcoholismo, trastornos alimentarios,
e incluso enfermedad cardiovascular.
El problema es que el impulso a rumiar puede sentirse muy fuerte e importante,
por lo que es un hábito difícil de detener.
Sé que esto es un hecho, ya que hace poco más de un año,
desarrollé el hábito yo mismo.
A mi hermano gemelo le diagnosticaron un linfoma no-Hodgkin en etapa III.
Su cáncer era extremadamente agresivo.
Tenía tumores visibles por todo el cuerpo.
Y tuvo que comenzar un curso de dura quimioterapia.
Y yo no podía dejar de pensar en lo que estaba pasando.
No podía dejar de pensar en lo mucho que sufría,
a pesar de que nunca se quejó ni una sola vez.
Tenía esta actitud increíblemente positiva.
Su salud psicológica fue increíble.
Yo estaba físicamente saludable, pero psicológicamente era un desastre.
Pero yo sabía qué hacer.
Los estudios dicen que incluso dos minutos de distracción son suficientes
para romper el impulso de rumiar en ese momento.
Así, cada vez que tenía un pensamiento inquietante, perturbador negativo,
me obligaba a concentrarme en otra cosa hasta que el impulso pasara.
Y en una semana, toda mi perspectiva cambió,
se hizo más positiva y más esperanzadora.
Nueve semanas después de que comenzó la quimioterapia, mi hermano tuvo un TAC,
y yo estaba a su lado cuando recibió los resultados.
Todos los tumores habían desaparecido.
Todavía tenía tres rondas más de quimioterapia,
pero sabíamos que se recuperaría.
Esta foto fue tomada hace dos semanas.
Al tomar acciones cuando se está solo,
al cambiar sus respuestas al fracaso,
al proteger su autoestima,
al luchar contra el pensamiento negativo,
uno no solo cura sus heridas psicológicas,
construye resistencia emocional, uno prospera.
Hace 100 años, la gente comenzó a practicar higiene personal
y las tasas de esperanza de vida aumentaron en más del 50 %
en apenas una cuestión de décadas.
Creo que nuestra calidad de vida podría aumentar así de drástico
si todos empezamos a practicar la higiene emocional.
¿Se imaginan lo que sería el mundo
si todo el mundo fuera psicológicamente saludable?
¿Si hubiera menos soledad y menos depresión?
¿Si la gente supiera cómo superar el fracaso?
¿Si se sintieran mejor sobre sí mismos y más al mando?
¿Si fueran más feliz y más plenos?
Yo puedo, porque ese es el mundo en el que quiero vivir
y que es el mundo en que mi hermano quiere vivir en también.
Y si Uds. se informan y cambian algunos hábitos simples,
bueno, eso es el mundo en el que todos podamos vivir.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)